[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: There's
this great technology
available in Android
called Google Now,
and I'd love to tell a
little story about it.
Last night I went to a
restaurant in Japantown,
and I just swiped
onto my phone, and I
saw all these great things that
were going on all around me.
There was this
museum I could visit.
There was the menu
for the restaurant
that I was actually in.
There were reviews
of that restaurant,
and thankfully they were good
reviews because I discovered it
after I was in there.
And there's all this great
stuff that Google Now
will actually give you.
But today I'm going
to be speaking
with our partner who, this
morning had a great keynote.
And one of the
things that stood out
was that, while my
smartphone was already smart,
you're working on things
to make it even smarter.
Can you tell us a
little bit about that?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: I
mean, don't get me wrong,
I love my smartphone.
I think they're getting
smarter over the years.
But I think the motivation was
to say, look, we really want
the technology to work for you.
Can we make the phone do
more of the work for you
so then you can get
on with your life.
If you think about it, that
sounds crazy and ambitious,
but we feel like
we've kind of taken
a few early steps towards that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Take
moon shots, right?
And some of the things
you've been doing about that,
the way I understand you've
been thinking about it
is that you think really
in terms of context,
and the things that are around
you, and answers to the things
that you might want to know, and
then actions that you can take.
Can you talk us
through that process?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
You've been paying attention
to the keynote.
that's good.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It was
hard not to, it was awesome!
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Now
look, if you think about it,
it sounds super cliched, super
obvious, but mobile changes
everything in terms of
how you find information.
How you act on it.
And then when you
think about it-- OK
that's the department
of obvious-- but then
if you unpack it, actually there
are three things going on here.
One is, of course, the
fact that your phone
is with you all the time.
Take my Disneyland
example from the morning.
The fact that you're
there is enough of a cue
that you need certain things.
You don't have to
actually spell it out.
You don't have to go
to a box and spell out,
oh I need X, Y and
Z. So the phone
has a lot of this
implicit context.
Context is the new black.
There's a whole
bunch of information
that you should
be able to tee up.
Your smartphone should
be able to tee up
without you having to sweat.
So that's one key insight, and
that's when we started saying,
well what are the kinds of
context where we can help?
A place is certainly
one of them,
like your in Japantown example.
But then, sometimes, the
context is in your head.
So in my case, for
example, I love cricket,
and I watch the World Cup.
I was maniacally
focused on that.
And so any information
around that
I don't have to spell it out.
Give it to me.
So that's another
context we think about.
And then, I think,
the other kind
of context we start to
think about is time.
So the fact that
around Thanksgiving you
need certain things,
or Halloween you're
looking up pumpkin patches.
So how do you really bring a lot
more information, without you
having to spell it out, is
our key motivation for this.
And then of course it gets
to answers, and actions.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
the context of places,
it's not just that this
place is in this location.
If it's a restaurant you've
got the opening hours,
you've got the menus,
you've got all that kind
of stuff, which is--
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: --very useful.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: I mean,
nobody thinks about, oh, I'm
in this lat long.
You're actually saying,
oh this is a restaurant,
or this is a mall.
At the mall you
want the directory,
at the airport you
want the terminal map.
In some sense it's
like you're trying
to get stuff done in a place.
You're not just there
for the sake of it.
So how are you going to get--
help you get stuff done?
LAURENCE MORONEY: And it's funny
you mentioned the cricket World
Cup, because it's
a great example.
I was in Australia
back in January.
And I didn't know about
the cricket World Cup.
And I'm from Ireland and I
heard that Ireland were going
to be in the cricket World Cup.
So I googled for, like, Ireland
and the cricket World Cup.
And then Google Now
started giving me
all this information, like
when they were going to play,
and the games that they won,
and the games that they lost.
It was really enriching,
and it was really
delightful to actually have it.
So some of the other things
that you spoke about now.
Some of the future
that you we're
talking about with Google Now.
This Google Now on
Tap, what's that
going to be bringing to us?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Not beer.
But the idea was
simple, which is saying,
look, like I was saying,
How can we bring you
answers and actions in context.
But then, if you think
about it, the context
is not just places,
time, and interest,
but very often,
the context is what
you're doing in that moment.
You are making dinner plans, or
you're talking about a movie.
In that context, in
that specific moment,
what do you need.
So we're kind of saying, OK, how
do we take this assistance that
were starting to build
with now, but then put it
to use in that precise moment?
And that's kind of
idea behind Now on Tap.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I liked
your Disney example,
instead of just telling me
what I can do in Disney,
its also got information
like, how long
the line is for this ride.
That's really,
really handy stuff.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
And with Now on Tap,
the other thing
that's interesting
is, we started out thinking,
oh, we should get you
quick answers, like, you and
I are talking about a movie,
give you the movie information.
But with user
studies, we actually
found another use case.
So one of the things
people said is,
oh, I have another
thing that I'm
super annoyed with
smartphones, which
is, I'm reading
something-- actually
this just happened
to me-- I was reading
some article about
free-range parenting,
and then I have to come do this.
And so I have two choices now.
Either I lose track
of it forever,
or I just fuss
with my phone right
before I come here,
and take 15 steps,
and add this to my
calendar, or whatever else.
So one of the
things we're saying
is, in that moment can you
just put a single button push
and just say, hey, Google
Now, get this back to me
when I can read it.
When I have the
context of reading it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah, like
with the Hugh Laurie example,
You were looking into him
and you held it down--
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Its
just a quick question.
I don't want to have to
go through 15 steps just
to get a quick
question answered.
LAURENCE MORONEY: --And
it was really funny,
because when I was watching
your keynote, and I was like,
I know Hugh Laurie
from somewhere.
And when you push
that, and then there
was a little icon of
an old British TV show,
called "Blackadder"
and he was in that
and I was like, ding! that's
where I know him from.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
Exactly, sometimes you just
have to see it for
a couple seconds.
Actually this happened to me, so
I always get confused between--
I still am confused-- between
Helen Hunt and Holly Hunter,
that always trips up--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Helen
Hunt, Holly Hunter,
yeah I can see that.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: They're
like two Hollywood actresses,
and I was like, which one
is it now, on an article.
And I was like, OK
let me tap on Holly.
And they said, oh yeah,
it's the other one.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
this is great stuff
for like, the end user.
How about for developers?
What kind of
goodness do we have?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: That's
the pretty cool thing here.
I think for developers,
there's a couple things.
One, your app, you don't
have to change anything.
That's why we're
using the platform
API to make this work, which is
the reason we have to roll it
out in M, Android M. But
the other thing is, like,
for "Tomorrowland," or for
restaurants, or whatever,
if you have an app that
can get something useful
done for that kind
of a use case,
you can start surfacing
here, which is pretty cool.
It's a new way, of
course now, today, you
can surface on Google Play,
Google Search as well,
this is a third way that
you can kind of reach users.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So if your
a domain expert in something
like, coffee shops that
have great latte art,
you can build the
app around that,
and then get surface to use
this through Now on Tap,
if you excuse the pun.
That's pretty good.
And when can we
expect to see this?
This is an Android M?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
Yes, It will roll out
with Android M in
a couple months.
We should see some updates to
the developer preview as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice,
so lots of great stuff
to look forward in Android
M. Google Now on Tap
is one of them.
I'm really excited for
that, thank you so much
for this Aparna.
Folks, download the developer
preview for M today.
You won't have the
Google Now on that yet,
but it's coming very, very soon.
So thanks, Aparna.